Now let's talk about the suite of technologies
that make civilization 3.0 possible
The firstis what I call mobile real
estate. We're also advancing in the area
of what google's Astro Teller calls mobile
infrastructure -- even movable cities.
First, they're settled communities with
a very light footprint; we're investing
in the technologies to nourish ourselves
without destabilizing the environment.
The Dutch for example have a national circular
strategy and towns that collect rain water and do
wastewater treatment and recycling they have solar
power and hydro and aquaponic agriculture. Okay,
small and mobile villages: that
sounds good for millions of people.
What about for hundreds of millions of
people? What about places like cairo? Cairo
faces insufficient Nile river water, while
Alexandria faces a rising Mediterranean sea.
The people of Alexandria and Cairo need
desalination and they need more efficient
crop irrigation, but beware of spending billions
of dollars on irrigation to sustain agriculture
in places where the water supply is at risk
and the delicate range of air temperature
that's right for growing food. Ultimately,
many people in egypt will have to relocate.
Skyscrapers could well become the stranded
assets and detritus of our present civilization
like the pyramids of ancient Egypt or
they may become air-conditioned shelters,
part of an archipelago of mixed-use facilities
all within a domed city; which is exactly what's
being planned for parts of Dubai. If we stay
where we are we are at best a survival society;
instead, we should move and we should build anew.